[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit niki
sie die schönen guten abend ihnen allen
positionen ist mit mir im studium hat
später die sportliche news hallo schön
gute nacht und das sind unsere themen an
diesem montag
deutsches signal an europa bundeskanzler
stolz wirbt in einer grundsatzrede für
mehr zusammenarbeit und schlägt etwa
eine gemeinsame luftabwehr vor
inspektion in der kampfzone
internationale experten sind auf dem weg
zum ukrainischen atomkraftwerks abriss
ja
[Musik]
52 millionen mal nahverkehr ohne limit
die verkehrsunternehmen ziehen eine
positive bilanz zum 9 euro ticket
nicht in brüssel nicht in paris sondern
in prag hielt kanzler scholz heute seine
erste große europa-rede langsam weg von
der einstimmigkeit und schrittweise hin
zu mehrheitsentscheidungen eine bessere
gemeinsame verteidigung sowie eine ost
erweiterung und eine neue handelspolitik
über diese forderungen und
reformvorschläge des kanzlers florian a
was kaiser karl der vierte im
spätmittelalter sagte war gesetz was
bundeskanzler scholz unter karls augen
heute vorträgt ist nur ein vorschlag wie
reagiert die eu auf den krieg gegen die
ukraine zum beispiel so scholz indem sie
weiter wächst
die ukraine
die republik moldau perspektivisch auch
georgien und natürlich die sechs staaten
des westlichen balkans gehören zu uns
zum freien demokratischen teil europas
davor aber so der bundeskanzler müsse
die eu sich selbst reformieren etwa
indem sie in der außenpolitik mit
mehrheit entscheidet stadt einstimmig
ein festhalten am prinzip der
einstimmigkeit funktioniert nur solange
der handlungsdruck gering ist
spätestens angesichts der zeitenwende
aber ist das nicht mehr der fall
zeitenwende auch militärisch deutschland
so scholz helfe der ukraine beim aufbau
eines luftabwehr systems ein solches
system wolle man nun auch für europa an
schaffen am besten gemeinsam
ein gemeinsam aufgebautes
luftverteidigungssystem in europa wäre
nicht nur kostengünstiger und
effizienter als wenn jeder von uns seine
eigene teure und hochkomplexe
luftverteidigung aufbaut es wäre ein
sicherheitsgewinn für ganz europa doch
wie schwer es wird seine eu partner von
mehrheitsentscheidungen zu überzeugen
erlebt olaf scholz nur wenig später in
zeiten der krise sagt da der
tschechische premier peter fiala gebe es
wichtigere themen als eine reform der eu
die tschechische regierung ist in diesem
fall sehr zurückhaltend und vorsichtig
übersetzt sie ist dagegen den abschied
von der einstimmigkeit aber müsste
europa einstimmig beschließen
theo koll war bei der rede in prag dabei
theo war sie denn so bedeutsamen wie das
kanzleramt angekündigt hat
also die zeiten sind ja moment als folge
des russischen angriffskrieg so in
bewegung dass auch maßvoll bedeutende
wegweiser ja schon beachtung verdienen
und das europäische gewicht deutschland
ist seit dem austritt der briten ja eher
noch gestiegen insofern ja diese erste
europapolitische rede des kanzlers war
wichtig und auch eine grundsätzliche
erklärung wohin olaf scholz europa in
der zeitenwende steuern will und in
gewisser weise ging ja auch noch das
lange und dröhnende berliner schweigen
nach der sorbonne rede von makro im raum
wie realistisch sind denn die umsetzung
dieser scholz forderung überhaupt und
ich glaube bei den vorschlägen zur
verteidigung und sicherheitspolitik mir
einiges machbar scholz will ja mehr
gemeinsame rüstung es gibt sagt er viel
zu viele unterschiedliche waffensystem
in europa und auch eine gemeinsame
luftverteidigung zu der die deutschen
dann maßgeblich beitragen wollen unter
anderem mit mitteln aus dem 100
milliarden sondervermögen das dürfte
umsetzbar sein aber die zentralen
europapolitischen reformvorschläge die
scheinen mir in hoher gefahr des
scheiterns das einstimmigkeitsprinzip
einzuschränken es braucht ja die
zustimmung genau derjenigen wie
beispielsweise ungarn die das system
bisher missbrauchen und davon
profitieren also unrealistisch und die
vorgeschlagene veränderung des
parlaments geht zu lasten der bisher
bevorzugten kleineren staaten auch die
werden das nicht aufgeben wollen der
prager gastgeber ministerpräsident jahre
hat dann heute auch prompt sehr
zurückhaltend reagiert es sei jetzt
keine günstige zeit für reformen
debatten danke für die einordnung theo
koll
jetzt in die ukraine da ist die lage im
und rund um das von russland besetzte
atomkraftwerk sabrina weiterhin ziemlich
brenzlig
auch heute gab es dort wieder angriffe
beide seiten machen sich gegenseitig
dafür verantwortlich und immer wieder
wird vor einer atomaren gefahr gewarnt
so auch durch die internationale
atomenergiebehörde die im laufe der
woche das akw inspizieren will art gänze
berichtet
heute nacht angriff auf in der roda die
stadt der ingenieure des atomkraftwerks
apres ski die ukraine macht russland
verantwortlich für den beschuss das
nahegelegene russisch besetzte
atomkraftwerk soll in wenigen tagen von
einem expertenteam der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde inspiziert werden
generaldirektor raphael mariano grossi
veröffentlicht heute dieses foto der
delegation sie kommen viel zu spät meint
eine mitarbeiterin die im atomkraftwerk
arbeitet und die wir heute erreichen sie
will nicht erkannt werden
die atomenergiebehörde hat nichts
gemacht um eine nukleare katastrophe zu
verhindern
die hier jederzeit passieren kann wegen
dieser untätigkeit hat die belegschaft
kein vertrauen zu dieser organisation
wir treffen einen ingenieur der bis ende
juli im atomkraftwerk arbeitete und dann
floh auch er will nicht erkannt werden
berichtet von einem klima der angst
die russen haben in kellern gefängnisse
eingerichtet und foltern dort
mitarbeiter die gegen die besatzung
protestieren ihnen wird in die beine
oder in die hände geschossen wir
vermissen 10 bis 20 kollegen wo sind sie
die russischen besatzer hätten schwere
waffen neben den reaktoren postiert und
würden auf ukrainische gebiete schießen
jede nacht feiern sie auf die andere
seite von dort kommen keine geschosse
zurück weil jeder versteht dass das ein
atomkraftwerk ist
viele ukraine flüchten aus dem russisch
besetzten air oder in der nähe des
atomkraftwerks du bist doch nicht frei
du bist dort in einem gefängnis sie ist
erst mal in sicherheit und hat eine neue
heimat gefunden im ukrainisch
kontrollierten gebiet
hannah hebestreit ist für uns ins labor
ist das ukrainische militär meldet dass
es im süden eine verteidigungslinie
durchbrochen habe russland weist dies
zurück was kannst du uns dazu sagen
das ist von hier sehr schwierig zu
bestätigen wir haben nur die information
vom oberkommando süd bekommen dass man
tatsächlich militärisch offensive
operationen gestartet habe in richtung
saison und es soll dabei tatsächlich
gebietsgewinne begeben haben das
bestätigen wohl auch blogger von mit
russischem hintergrund
insgesamt hat sich das ukrainische
militär sehr offen sehr zuversichtlich
gezeigt dass man erfolg haben könne man
warnt aber vor zu großer zuversicht man
sagt der bevölkerung das wird dauern das
sei keine sache von stunden oder von
tagen außerdem möge man sich bitte
darauf vorbereiten ist es gefährlich
werden können man solle sich essen und
getränke bereit stellen und in
sicherheit gehen von seiten russischer
nachrichtenagentur hören wir dass in den
gebieten viele mitarbeiter ihre
arbeitsplätze verlassen haben und sich
in bunker zurückgezogen haben sei aber
nicht geplant die gebiete zu räumen
hier war das heute morgen so dass diese
ganzen eilmeldungen auf dem handy ist
unser ukrainischen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter auftauchten das schon sehr
große spannung zu spüren war so etwas
wie ein druckausgleich geht es jetzt ja
doch los
es bleibt unübersichtlich vielen dank
nach sabrina hebestreit in der ukraine
für uns jetzt nach deutschland da frisst
die hohe inflation weiterhin die
lohnerhöhungen auf das hat das
statistische bundesamt errechnet demnach
wuchsen im zweiten quartal zwar die
bruttomonatsverdienste
aber noch stärker stiegen die
verbraucherpreise im schnitt betrage der
lohn rückgang mehr als vier prozent die
inflation trifft ja vor allem menschen
mit niedrigen und mittleren einkommen
wie man sie stärker entlasten kann auch
darum geht es bei der kabinettsklausur
morgen in meseberg und inmitten der
differenzen innerhalb der ampel kommen
aus der spd-fraktion konkrete
entlastungsvorschläge last bohnsack wie
umgehen mit rasanten preissteigerungen
die spd fraktion fordert in einem
entwurf direktzahlungen für menschen mit
kleinem einkommen keine strom und gas
sperren den privaten haushalten sechs
monate kündigungsschutz für mieter die
ihre nebenkosten nicht zahlen und ein
üppiges für 49 euro monatlich
wenn ich mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern
rede alle sind in großer sorge vor dem
nächsten monaten alle wissen dass da
eine echt harte phase auf sie zukommt
dass sie den gürtel enger schnallen
müssen dass gespart werden muss die
grünen würden mit den vorschlägen der
spd wohl mit gehen fordern zur
finanzierung aber auch krisengewinnler
abzuschöpfen
gibt auch noch die möglichkeit so lange
der energiemarkt nicht reformiert ist
die immensen über gewinne die bei
einigen firmen momentan fallen
abzugreifen und damit dann eine
lastverteilung von denen zu machen die
im moment wirklich ein schweinegeld
verdienen zu den menschen die dieses
geld dringend brauchen eine über gewinn
steuer lehnt die fdp jedoch kategorisch
ab der finanzminister will vor allem
steuerliche entlastungen für mittlere
einkommen wenn im nächsten jahr 40.000
euro einkommen durch die inflation und
auf 37.000 euro wert sind durch eben die
preissteigerungen dann dürfen diese dann
37.000 euro nicht besteuert werden als
wären es noch 40 diese vielstimmigkeit
macht es der opposition leicht die
handlungsfähigkeit der regierung in
frage zu stellen bei der bundesregierung
in der ampel gibt es ankündigungen es
gibt zum teil versprechungen aber es
wird nichts konkret bisher auf den weg
gebracht weil sich die
koalitionsfraktion gegenseitig
blockieren morgen kommt die regierung
zur klausur in meseberg zusammen nach
einer einigung auf ein neues hilfspaket
sieht es derzeit eher nicht aus
ein teil der bisherigen entlastungen ist
noch bis mittwoch dass neun euro ticket
günstig einfach und ziemlich beliebt
insgesamt 52 millionen tickets sind laut
verband deutscher verkehrsunternehmen in
den vergangenen drei monaten verkauft
worden dazu kommen billig fahrscheine
für rund 10 millionen menschen die schon
ein monats-abo hatten zehn prozent aller
fahrten hätten das auto ersetzt mehr von
susanne santina
fordern sie in berlin auch vom
bundesfinanzminister
450.000 unterschriften haben greenpeace
und die bürgerbewegung kompakt gesammelt
sie alle wollen dass neun euro ticket
bundesweit bis ende des jahres und eine
anschlusslösung es ist zum einen ein
sehr effizientes und konsequentes
klimaschutz instrument und bringt die
soziale entlastung die auch wirklich bei
den menschen ankommt diese erfolge
bestätigt auch die studie des verbands
deutscher verkehrsunternehmen rund 52
millionen euro tickets wurden verkauft
die große mehrheit der käufer war
zufrieden und jeder fünfte war neukunde
hinzu kommt der beachtliche klima aspekt
noch drei monaten über 1,8 millionen
tonnen co2 reden die wir dadurch
eingespart haben weil das entspricht
ungefähr an einem jahr tempolimit auf
deutschen autobahnen in den letzten drei
monaten wurden aber auch die defizite
offengelegt zum teil völlig überfüllte
züge ausgefallene verspätete
verbindungen fehlendes personal den
reformbedarf betont auch der
bundesverkehrsminister zweiter stelle
sich die frage nach den kosten welchen
beitrag können die länder leisten die ja
die originäre zuständigkeit haben aber
die dritte frage die ist dann eben auch
wichtig wie können wir gemeinsam eine
finanzierung sicherstellen bestätigt hat
die studie auch die geringe resonanz im
ländlichen raum nur halb soviel verkäufe
wie in städtischen gebieten was vor
allem an den fehlenden bindungen und der
langen fahrt dauer liege auch hier gibt
es also reformbedarf trotzdem das fazit
des verkehrsverbundes dass neun euro
ticket war ein voller erfolg
der energiekonzern juniper hat weitere
vier milliarden euro staatliche hilfe
beantragt die bisherigen neun milliarden
euro an krediten von der staatlichen kfw
bank seien schon vollständig
ausgeschöpft seit heute morgen
produziert eines von junipers
steinkohlekraftwerken wieder strom
heiden 4 ist eines der
leistungsstärksten und geht
vorübergehend wieder ans netz um gas
einzusparen greenpeace nannte die
reaktivierung bitter aber unumgänglich
die gemeinden in deutschland haben
vergangenes jahr eine rekord summe aus
der gewerbesteuer eingenommen insgesamt
gut 61 milliarden euro laut
statistischem bundesamt der höchste
stand seit erhebung der daten
1991 und sogar mehr als vor der korona
pandemie die gemeinden hatten die
gewerbesteuer 2020 leicht angehoben noch
immer ist nicht eindeutig klar was zum
fischsterben in der oder vierter zu viel
salz zu hohe temperaturen eine alge
klar ist entlang der oder von der region
um breslau auf bis zur mündung in die
ostsee wurden schon mehr als 200 tonnen
tote fische eingesammelt und viele
weitere kadaver sind wohlauf den
flussgrund gesunken und jetzt heißt es
aufklären und konsequenzen aus der
katastrophe ziehen darum traf sich der
deutsch polnische umwelt rate im
brandenburgischen bad saarow mehr von
jan meyer ein wenig hat sich die oder
erholt doch niedrigwasser hitze und
salzhaltige abwässer können auch künftig
die im fluss schaden hinzu kommt polen
wir die oder für große schiffe
ausbaggern zu lasten von
rückzugsgebieten für zahlreiche fische
umweltministerin lemke versuchte deshalb
ihre amtskollegin von diesen plänen
abzubringen
deshalb finde ich dass die
ausbaumaßnahmen gestoppt werden müssen
mindestens ausgesetzt werden müssen
darüber haben wir keine einigkeit
erreicht dazu gibt es unterschiedliche
ansichten
und ich finde dass man das gegenseitig
respektieren kann doch an der moskwa
verwies auf einen vertrag von 2015
damals vereinbarten beide länder den
ausbau für schiffe so groß wie sie auf
dem rhein verkehren
möchte mit allem nachdruck erklären das
abkommen zum oder ausbau gilt für beide
seiten meine pflicht ist es das
umzusetzen
in bad saarow wurden die gegensätze klar
auch deutsche erwartungen einer
schnellen aufklärung der ursache des
fischsterbens dämpfte polens ministerin
man warte noch auf laborergebnisse
umweltschützer zeigten sich enttäuscht
von den ergebnissen besonders von polens
festhalten am oder ausbau wir haben
anders als zu dem zeitpunkt 2015 als
dieser plan
ausbau der oder entstand ganz andere
klimatische bedingungen das sollte auch
eine polnische regierung irgendwie sehen
können immerhin einigten sich beide
ministerinnen darauf experten klären zu
lassen wie genau sich der schwer
geschädigte fluss vollständig erholen
kann
eigentlich sollte heute der tag sein an
dem die nasa zum ersten mal seit 50
jahren wieder zum mond fliegt wenn auch
ohne menschen an bord aber die
us-weltraumbehörde hat die sogenannte
artemis mission verschoben kurz vor dem
start wurden probleme mit einem der
raketentriebwerke gemeldet viele
menschen hatten sich an der küste
floridas versammelt wollten das
spektakel live miterleben als
nächstmöglichen starttermin nannte die
nasa freitag oder montag nächste woche
und für uns ganz in der nähe von cape
canaveral ist so seine freitag susanne
die artemis mission die wurde lange die
wurde akribisch vorbereitet wie groß ist
jetzt die enttäuschung
es kommt darauf an aus welcher
perspektive man das betrachtet die
wissenschaftler sagen wir waren uns
nicht ganz sicher dass die rakete
wirklich gut starten kann also ist es
sicherer sie am boden zu lassen damit
man sie nicht hoch schickt und damit
viele milliarden dollar in den sand
setzt sozusagen aus der perspektive der
menschen ist es natürlich schon eine
gewisse enttäuschung die haben zum teil
die ganze nacht am am rand des launch
pad was man hier hinter mir sieg
gekämpft und wollten natürlich unbedingt
diesen historischen rum erleben dass da
sind ganz viele menschen gekommen die
auch selber am raketenbau schon
mitgearbeitet haben im moment gibt die
nasa gerade eine pressekonferenz und hat
eben gesagt und zwar das risiko zu groß
wir konnten uns das nicht leisten die
situation sicherheit geht einfach immer
vor und es wird jetzt natürlich
fieberhaft nach den ursachen gesucht und
man wird auch gucken welche konsequenzen
das haben wird es gibt zwei alternativ
termine freitag und montag wenn man aber
feststellen sollte dass man eines der
triebwerke austauschen müsste dann kann
es sein dass sich der start in den
oktober verschiebt das wird man jetzt
abwarten müssen jedenfalls wenn man von
außen betrachtet sagen würde es ist
peinlich dass diese rakete nicht
gestartet ist das stimmt nicht weil es
ist so ein hochkomplexes gerät was noch
nie gebaut wurde das sowas eigentlich
normal ist dass haben uns hier auch
viele leute gesagt da war die
enttäuschung hielt sich in grenzen weil
man sagte sicherheit geht vor man muss
damit leben und raketenstarts
verschieben sich häufig dann vielen dank
für das update susanne mit uns können
sie aber trotzdem zum mond fliegen
erkunden sie online und in unserer zdf
reuter interaktiv die geplante
raumstation außerdem erfahren sie mehr
über die mond-mission artemis und das
große eigentliche ziel den mars in
der bundesliga hat bayern münchen am
wochenende wenn man so will einen
leichten dämpfer erhalten rudi genau
unentschieden gegen borussia
mönchengladbach aber trotz des 1 2 1
blicken die bayern zuversichtlich auf
die kommenden wochen der wahrheit
bereits am zweiten spieltag der
champions league kommt es zu einem
wiedersehen mit robert lewandowski der
zum fc barcelona abgewanderten beim 4 0
gegen valladolid drehte der ex-bayer so
richtig auf
er hat gut zwinkern robert lewandowski
verstärkt seinen neuen verein den fc
barcelona auch mit 34 jahren noch in
weltklasse manier gestern am späten
abend trifft der polnische top stürmer
gleich zwei mal unnachahmlich
lewandowski like eine demonstration
ausgerechnet einen tag nachdem die
bayern ausnahmsweise probleme haben mit
dem erfolgreichen torabschluss den
vereitelt mönchengladbachs yann sommer
insgesamt gleich 19 mal bundesliga
rekord bis dann der ausgleich gelingt
als allerdings danach julian nagelsmann
den duft für 67 millionen euro
eingekauften abwehrchef mattes licht für
den torschützen sami als mittel sturm
joker einsetzt liegt eine frage auf der
hand wünschen sich die bayern robert
lewandowski zurück
also ich würde ja sagen wenn wir heute
keine chance gehabt hätten und irgendwie
nicht zu einem abschluss gekommen werden
dann würde ich sagen der der level
vielleicht aus dem nichts nur eine
gemacht im september treffen die bayern
in der champions league auf barcelona
wird spannend hat doch lewandowski
allein in der königsklasse in seiner
karriere schon 86 mal das tor getroffen
ja und soeben ist tatjana maria als
erste deutsche tennis spielerin bei den
us open in new york ausgeschieden die 35
jährige aus bad saulgau hier im bild
oben unterlag der weltranglisten dritte
maria zaccaria aus griechenland in drei
sätzen mit 4 6 6 3 und 0 6 für tatjana
maria die beim rasen klassiker in
wimbledon noch überraschend das
halbfinale erreicht hatte kam das aus
beim letzten grand-slam-turnier des
jahres diesmal in der ersten runde
ja und das war schade schade aber danke
danke was er nicht aussagen keine ruhige
sommerwetter das sagt gleich katja
honnefer voraus mit leider weiterhin
wenig regen dort war besonders fehlt
spd-chef klingbeil im interview mit
christian sievers ab 21 uhr 45 im heute
journal ja so viele von uns schön
dankeschön abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend wenn sie ganz genau
hinschauen dann sehen sie hier den
niebel an der donau der sich im laufe
des tages auflöste das unwetter tief der
vergangenen woche hat inzwischen das
baltikum erreicht für uns interessant
ist aber auch dieses tief über spanien
denn das schaufelt uns aus frankreich
schwülwarme gewitter luft heran aber
noch nicht in dieser nacht lang ist
allenfalls ihr aussehen noch letzte
regenschauer im südwesten ist es dagegen
klar die temperaturen sinken meist auf
13 bis 8 grad milder bleibt die nach dem
rhein main gebiet und an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee mit 15 grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen im
norden und im nordosten bei 19 bis 22
grad sonst werden 23 bis 30 grad
erreicht und der tag beginnt nach nebel
oft sehr freundlich sonne und wolken
wechseln sich ab allenfalls im nordosten
gibt es noch ein paar spritzer regen
nachmittags aber werden dann die wolken
im südwesten wieder größer werden es
gibt die ersten regenschauer und
gewitter die weiten sich dann in der
nacht zu mittwoch und mittwoch über tag
dann auf ganz baden württemberg aus und
erreichen auch bayern in norddeutschland
gab es dagegen sonnig und in den
nächsten tagen ist es meist freundlich
einzelne gewitter drohen dann er da am
freitag getan